well thank you thank you so much for
having me it's a pleasure to be here and
yeah and I hope maybe some of the things
that I talk about may give some
inspiration for you HCI guys
um so I lead the causality and cognition
lab in the psychology department
and we're interested in how people
understand causality and basically how
the world works and how they understand
each other right and we're interested in
how people learn about the causal
structure of the world how they once
they have it in their mind how they can
use it to reason about the world make
predictions make inferences about the
past or think about maybe also how
things could have played out differently
from how they actually did
and how those capacities also allow us
to make the kind of judgments we do in
our everyday lives that's like for
example assigning responsibility to one
another
and that's in fact one of the bigger
sort of overarching goals that my lab is
working toward maybe developing a
computational framework for
understanding responsibility
and I think to get there we have to be
able to answer at least two questions
namely one being what causal role
somebody's action played and bringing
about the outcome and the other one
being with the action that the person
took tells us about the kind of person
that they are
for this first one we need some
intuitive theory of how the world works
so we can relate the actions that
somebody took to the kind of outcomes
that resulted from those actions
and for the second question we need some
intuitive theory of how people work so
we can go backwards from the actions
that we've observed to the mental states
that may have given rise to those
actions so what were the person's
intentions what did they believe what
were the kinds of things maybe that they
were able to do as well
and so I studied psychology like in my
undergrad and I was most excited about
social psychology because I felt sort of
most applicable I guess to my everyday
life and somehow also got into
responsibility like back then already
maybe it was because I was in some group
project where I felt I was doing all the
heavy lifting and maybe I wasn't getting
all the credit for it so so that was
sort of what interested me initially
and and when I read Around in in in that
work in social psychology a lot of the
theories that I saw took a form sort of
like this so I'll just give you a few um
examples so basically sort of like you
know boxes and arrows theories where
they identified important Concepts that
were related to how we assign
responsibility and maybe also roughly
how they were related to one another
um but still left a lot in a certain way
unspecified
so this is a quote from Bertram Mali
from a while ago he says like an
important limitation of many of these
models of moral judgment or assigning
responsibility is They Don't Really
generate any quantitative predictions
and you might say like oh what do you
need quantitative predictions for well
one one thing that they're useful for is
sort of you know laying your cards out
and making it concrete what your model
does also allows it then to be falsified
more easily now remember this one
instance it was like me I think maybe
first year of my PhD I went to this
conference and had dinner you know with
one of the one of the people who made
one of these sort of boxes and arrow
diagrams and I told them about some
experiment that I thought that had
thought of and thought like oh this
would happen and and I think that would
be the result of that experiment and and
I was very I felt very smart I thought
like oh this would totally kind of
disprove your theory right and he said
no no that would be totally consistent
with my theory and I thought oh that's
weird I maybe I really tried to
understand the theory very well and and
um so so that also was a sort of a
little bit of a moment for me that I
felt like okay maybe it's important to
try to make these theories even more
precise so we know what it is that
they're predicting so we can go about
and you know falsify them and sort of
improve them and so that's been very
much kind of an inspiration for me what
I've been trying to do a little bit
um and so one of the starting points in
almost all of these theories of
responsibility is there's causality
always causality comes first so I
thought okay let me try let me try that
one so can we get more specific about
what it means you know or what people
um what it takes for people to say that
one thing caused another thing to happen
and so I think there are three key
ingredients that we need like in order
to get a theory for how people think
that one one thing caused another thing
to happen
and those are starting with a mental
model that people have of a particular
domain a mental model that allows us to
conceive of counterfactual interventions
so and I'll flesh it out a little bit
more in a moment so imagining how things
could have been different from how they
actually were and that it allows us then
to mentally simulate what the
consequences of this counterfactual
intervention would have been
and so the idea of mental models has
been around you know for quite some time
and has recently gotten a little bit
more attention again also in Ai and but
but yeah some of the credity at least in
modern times should go to the
philosopher Kenneth Craig in his book
the nature of explanation who said
something along the lines or well he
said exactly that but I'm going to say
what along the lines so that we have
something like a small scale model oh
wouldn't it be very helpful if we had
something like a small scale model of
the world in our minds that we can then
use for all sorts of things like
predicting what was going to happen if I
did this rather than actually having to
carry out the action and then you know
dying maybe if it was a bad one
um and and yeah that would be really
helpful for decision making and as I
will say in a moment also really helpful
for explaining kind of why something
happened
so this idea of mental models has been
around for a very long time and then in
somewhat more recent years at least in
cognitive science has been made a little
bit more concrete particularly as it
pertains to our mental model of the
physical world right
and so the idea is he was here to say
like well maybe our mental model of the
physical world is in certain respects
similar to the kinds of physics engines
that we use to make realistic um
computer games it's a common move right
you have some some tool and then you
think like okay maybe the mind is a
little bit like that tool so this was
just you know psychologists playing
Angry Birds and then thinking like okay
maybe the mind is a little bit like um
like Angry Birds
so here um the basic idea right is that
we take in the world you know through
our perceptual senses and that we then
build this internal representation of
the world that's not a physics engine
kind of representation so that we pass
the world for example into objects and
the properties of those objects and then
the interactions between those objects
so here um this child may be passes the
world into the ball and then the eagle
on top of the tower and then the the
Tower or the blocks that um that make up
the tower
and now that you have this internal
representation of the world you can use
it for example for for planning so if
this child for example wants to topple
over that Tower they can think about
what's going to happen if they roll the
ball like in different kinds of ways so
I can run simulations using this
internal engine in my mind
so having this would be very useful
because I could make predictions about
the future I could pay sort of Sherlock
and infer from the current state of the
world what must have happened in the
past and as I'll show in a moment this
would also be useful for explaining
something that happened in the present
okay so what I'll do is in in this in
the remaining time right I'll I'll
basically want to cover these two
different aspects of um of working
towards this computational Frameworks
and part one I'm going to focus on the
physical domain and then in part two I'm
going to expand it to to start to think
about people
I should say Obviously feel free to ask
questions like anytime throughout
otherwise I'll try and end you know
around
um 12 20 so that we have a little bit of
time also for Q a um at the end but feel
free to ask and throughout if anything's
unclear
okay so let's start with this part one
and and I should also warn you there is
a little bit of audience participation
required so get get ready for that
so the first we started really simple
right I was saying okay I want to
understand causality a little bit better
what's the simplest possible setting
maybe in which you could think about
causality
um well it's two billiard balls
colliding with one another
and here's the first audience
participation part so there's going to
be these two balls coming in on the
right side of the screen and I'm going
to ask you whether you think that ball a
caused B to go through the gate and if
you think so maybe just raise your arm
like at the end of the video clip so
here's what's happening
okay so who thinks that a caused me to
go through the gate in this case
okay a lot of other people do anyone
think that they didn't
no one there is okay cool so um you're
in line with what most people say um in
this case and um and here's you know
what I think was going on in your minds
not the part not the motor part of
raising your your hand but the kind of
judgment the part of yeah what's the
acquisition happening in this case and
the first part is very kind of
uncontroversial so you looked at what
actually happened right you saw that
they collided with one another and it
will be ended up going through the gate
and now the somewhat more controversial
part is to say that well that's in
itself is not sufficient right that that
does not contain all the information you
need in order to say that a caused W to
go through the gate in this case what
you also need is something like this
right you need the capacity to simulate
in your mind in this case that removing
basically from ball a from the scene
kind of in your mind right and then and
then simulating web well we would have
kind of probably haven't been present in
the scene maybe you all sort of
naturally and spontaneously did that and
of course I already talked a little bit
about about kind of factuals and stuff
like that in the experiment of course I
don't do that right I just ask people to
make causal judgments
so the so the simple idea here right is
then to say when do you say that a
caused me to go through the gate it's
really sort of like an epistemic notion
so you're subjective degree of belief
well to the extent that you think that
um what would have happened in the
actual so uh that what would have
happened in the counterfactual situation
would have been different from the thing
that actually happened that determines
um your extent to which you say that
yeah a caused me to go through the gain
and here you're probably pretty sure in
this instance that we would have missed
that they hadn't been there so you say
yes a Costa to go through
and just a little bit in terms of sort
of you know background a lot of the
inspiration for this kind of work comes
from Judea Pearl's work on on causality
and some of you may have may have heard
of his work and and there they use
different kinds of generative models to
capture people's causal knowledge of the
world so this could be something like
causal based Nets or structural
equations
um that you may also remember from your
you know stats class if you had one
um and then you define some kind of
operations on these models to to support
things like kind of factual reasoning so
imagining that like some variable had
been replaced with another one for
example
and so I'm doing something quite similar
here only in that I'm assuming that the
generative model that people have of the
world in this case is somewhat richer
than what can be represented with these
causal basis or structural equations so
in my case the generative model that I
assume people have in their mind is
something like the physics engine that I
actually use to generate them and the
stimuli and I'll make that noisy I'll
show I'll show you in a second how I'm
making it noisy
and then I also have to think about okay
what another kind of factual uh
intervention operators that you might
have over a representation like this one
and in this case it could be something
like imagining that an object wouldn't
have been that would not have been there
for example
okay so you might think now okay well
maybe that's the only game in town like
what else could you possibly be doing in
a setting like this and at least luckily
for me there has been a lot of you know
philosophers and psychologists that have
argued for what I called these actualist
theories of causation and they basically
just say you don't need that part right
all you need all the information you
need to to give causal judgments or
cause explanations of what happened is
there in the actual situation in some
sense
and so one of the best kind of worked
out accounts of that in in Psychology
comes from a psychologist called Philip
wolf and and he calls it the force
Dynamics model of causation
and the idea is that all you need to pay
attention to is the forces that are
associated with um the agent and the
patient that's the sort of lingo they
use
um and you then you just look needs to
look at how these forces are configured
and that helps you to say what in this
case here there's different causal
Expressions is appropriate to use in a
particular situation and I'll just apply
it to this example here so we have the
patient which is Paul B that has a force
that is associated with it then we have
an agent that applies a force to the
patient in this case as a function of
these two forces we have some resulting
Force here and then in this case the
patient also ended up reaching the end
State and because this configuration
looks like that and that maps onto this
Force configuration Philip Wolf's
account would also here say yes a COS B
to go through the gate so this clip
would not help us actually tease apart
this other model that I've been kind of
promoting so just to make this
distinction sort of clear or clearer so
in the force Dynamics model you start
with some intuitive theory of how the
world Works which in this case are these
little Force vectors that apply to age
and patients and you can then directly
go from there to making causal judgments
so there's this direct route from this
kind of intuitive Theory to causal
judgment
he also says that you can do counter
factuals too by imagining for example if
one of the forces hadn't been there what
would have happened in this situation
but that's not necessary to figure out
whether something caused something to
happen
and sort of what I'm arguing for is sort
of a slightly different picture but
where I'm saying well first of all I
start with a slightly different theory
of um of the domain in this case again
using the physics engine rather than
using these Force vectors but then
saying that you have to go through this
process of counter factual simulation to
say that um something caused something
to happen
and what I'm going to try and do in the
next you know two slides to sort of
motivate um motivate that account
one way to motivate it first is that I
started off saying like I want to have
this model of responsibility right so
and that means that I want to have a
model of causation that that not only
narrowly applies to the physical world
but that can also be applied to for
example the kind of causation that
happens between people right and here's
just some examples of causal statements
that you could hear at the fall of
Lehman Brothers caused the financial
crisis my housemates failure to what are
my plans cost them to die
realizing that he forgot his wallet at
home caused him to go back you probably
wouldn't say that exactly in English but
they all seem fine sort of causal things
like to say right and it's probably a
little bit tricky or at least I would
find it tricky to think how would I
explain these sorts of causations with
Force vectors right and the hope is that
the account that I'm developing is a
little bit more flexible so that it can
apply to these sorts of situations as
well
but now and and another kind of
um key Advantage I think of the model
that we've been developing is that it
actually allows us to derive
quantitative predictions and it's hence
more easily falsifiable that some of the
prior work and so you can falsify it if
you like write a paper Toby was wrong
and then I have to go back to the office
and you know uh improve improve the
account
so here's a way in which we're getting
quantitative predictions out of this
model but I was saying that how um you
may cause the judgments is by comparing
what actually happened with what would
have happened in the relevant kind of
factual situation
but now you don't know that right the
thing that I'm showing here on the right
hand side I guess that's in some sense
the grand truth right but you don't you
don't get to see that right you only see
what actually happens you don't get to
see what would have happened if poly
hadn't been there
so you have to use your intuitive
understanding again of this domain to
simulate what would have happened in
this kind of factual
and so one way for us to capture this
uncertainty that you may have about
exactly what would have happened if Paul
a hadn't been there is by generating
simulations from our physics engine but
now injecting a little bit of noise into
that engine so now it becomes sort of
like a probabilistic program because
it's now not a deterministic outcome
anymore
um if poly hadn't been there but rather
what I'm doing is I'm generating a
simulated sample from my model and now
in this case there's many different ways
in which you could make your model kind
of random or uncertain here what we did
is we just took the actual ground truth
you know that ball B velocity that Bobby
you know would have had and applied a
small perturbation to the velocity
Vector at each point in time right so
now it's sort of like in your simulation
when you're imagining where Bobby would
have gone it's sort of like you know
Jiggles a little bit along the way
and so this might be now one outcome
like of such a sample so if you think
like oh oh I think I would have missed
but let me try again like oh yeah I
think it would have missed yeah I'm
pretty sure it would have missed right
so this is just multiple times sampling
in your mind of what would have happened
if poly hadn't been there and here since
all of them you're pretty sure that it
would have missed you said yeah a Costa
to go through
but you can probably already anticipate
we can now do a slightly different case
right where in the actual situation
again still a and a collides with B and
B goes in but this time it's sort of
less clear what would have happened if
Paul a hadn't been present in the scene
right because that Bobby is headed like
right to the to the goal posts
essentially and now if you apply the
same idea of simulating with noise what
would have happened you know in some
cases maybe Bobby would have missed but
it's also possible that Bobby would have
gone in anyhow even if they hadn't been
there and that accordingly you might say
like yeah I'm less sure you know that a
cause will be to go through the gate in
this case
so that's what we did now in our
experiment where we showed people a
bunch of Clips like this one so here's
just um three different ones like one
clip in which um you know it's pretty
clear here at the top that um
um Ball B would have missed it probably
hadn't been there the one in the middle
is like one this kind of close call and
then the one on the right hand side is
one in which um it was pretty clear that
Bobby would have gone in anyhow even if
a hadn't been there
and then between experiments we either
asked them some kind of factual question
so that's the one here at the bottom the
blue one do you think that Bobby would
have missed if ball a hadn't been there
and then we see that in this case
they're pretty sure yeah I think it
would have missed yeah they're right at
the midpoint of the scale not not sure
right whether whether I would have
missed or not so we give them some
slider where they can just evaluate
their their degree of beliefs and then
in this case they're pretty sure that it
would have um uh you know that it would
not have missed even if poly hadn't been
there
and then we take a separate group of
participants and we ask them a causal
question so those participants don't
hear anything about counterfactuals we
just ask them in a clip like that what
do you think that well a caused will be
to go through the gate
and we see that their judgments align
very closely with those of the ones in
the counter factual
um question condition
and we can also use that model right
that I described that draws these
samples and tries to simulate what would
have happened and it also yields very
similar judgments um in this or makes
predictions in this case
these are just three of the video clips
we had like 18 different clips in that
experiment and if you just line up here
on the x-axis the average count of
factual judgments that participants made
and on the y-axis the average causal
ratings that participants gave you see
that they're very closely lined with one
another at least suggesting like a
strong relationship between these kinds
of judgments
but when we you know publish this work
as a cocci paper so for the cognitive
science proceedings one of the reviewers
you know they were mostly happy with it
but one of the reviewers saying like
yeah but you know all of the clips that
you show participants something slightly
different was going on so maybe you just
didn't try hard enough to come up with
an actualist account like one that only
looks at what actually happened and if
you tried a little bit harder then you
could have you know you could have
explained it away
so we did try and we didn't succeed but
it's also sort of a weird position that
you're in when you kind of don't want to
succeed right so so we thought like okay
maybe the better thing rather than being
crappy at modeling you know just let's
come up with an experiment where it
feels like if it comes up in the way
that we think it will there's no way you
could possibly explain it with an
actualist account and so that's that's
the route we took so just really think
like oh are these counter factors really
necessary for understanding causal
judgments so second round of audience
participation get get ready I'm just
going to show you a slightly different
clip and this time I'm going to ask you
whether you think that ball a prevented
Bobby from going through the gate
yeah
okay what do you think this if you think
that ball a prevented will be from going
through the gate you can raise your hand
okay few people think so in this case
okay I'll show you another one
this was not some kind of you know
glitch I I was having fun you know doing
the the physics engine and sort of
playing Portal right by turning these
things into a Teleport right now I
didn't tell you anything about them of
course when I showed you the first clip
but maybe just seeing that one clip you
already have like one shot learning yeah
okay maybe that's a Teleport and the
teleport it works only for Ball B you
know it doesn't work for ball a and the
yellow thing is that the entry of the
teleport and the blue thing is the exit
of the teleport
and now that I've shown you that if I
now show you exactly the same clip again
you're going to say at least if you like
my participants yes it prevented it from
going through right because now what
changed is basically your belief about
how the world works such that your
counter Factor looks a little bit more
like that now right what would have
happened is that it would have gone
through the teleport and into the goal
right so the fact that I can show you
exactly the same clip twice right and
and all I've changed was your belief
about how the world works and that makes
a big difference to your causal judgment
sort of shows that it cannot be
sufficient
um to explain causal judgment just in
terms of what actually happened because
actually what actually happened was
exactly the same in both of the times
that I showed you the clip
I don't need to do the teleport thing
the teleport thing is cute because I can
show you exactly the same clip but I can
also move some obstacle in and out of
the way right here on the left hand side
you're not going to say that a prevented
me from going through the gate on the
right hand side you are because the
block is out of the way right in a
similar way for causation in the on the
left hand side you're going to say yeah
a caused it because the block would have
blocked it and on the right hand say
you're not really going to say that it
caused it because it would have gone in
anyhow right same idea I'm doing exactly
the same interactions between the balls
I'm just changing something kind of in
the background that affects the counter
factual and thereby also affects
people's causal judgments
okay so another thing that's sort of
neat about this model is that it doesn't
only kind of predict basically
um the Judgment that people should give
at the end of it but also says something
about the cognitive process by which
they arrive at the Judgment right in
this case is maybe this process of
mental stimulation that you're kind of
generating these samples and thinking
about what would have happened and that
those Drive the cause of judgment
and one way we can do that or can sort
of get more direct evidence on that is
to use eye tracking right to see okay
where is it that you're looking at when
you're asked to make causal judgments in
these kinds of video clips
so we went back to the really simple
ones again and now also between
experiments just ask participants a
different question about the video that
that
um that they would see and they knew at
the beginning what question they would
be asked so we had one condition here
that we call the outcome condition where
they'd watch the video and we just ask
them at the end in this case if it ended
up missing did be completely miss the
gate
and so I'll show you the the eye
movements of one of the participants in
this condition and I'm going to play the
video at half speed and do some sort of
live narration as it unfolds
so the blue dot is the eye movement
right so the participant here is looking
back and forth between ball a and ball b
so looking looking at Ball B sort of now
trying to extrapolate where B will end
up hitting the wall
and
then mostly looking at Bobby
not very exciting but also that's all
they need to know right in order to
answer this question in this case
so now if you take a different
participant who was asked to make a
causal question so asked to answer
across the question in the video but
otherwise saw exactly the same video
clips as other participant did you're
going to see that the eye movements look
quite different and they look different
in a way that made me very happy at the
time so so you see they're not just
looking at Bobby they're trying to
anticipate web well B would have gone
you know if Paul Avon wasn't present in
the scene and it's quite likely that
when you guys when I showed you this
first video clip that you did that right
and and it may not even been super you
know aware to you that you did do that
like I haven't really checked you know
um yeah how well at some point at the
beginning when I ran this on a laptop I
would sometimes see that people would
use their finger or they would use their
you know kind of pen or something and
that's of course pretty aware I guess
right
um but but it's possible that with the
eye movements this sort of come so
natural to us that we know you don't
even realize that we're engaging kind of
in this kind of process but but yeah I
was very happy you know when um when I
saw this happening and
um so this is anecdotal in a sense it's
just one video clip right but we can
also look at more generally sort of
analyzing the differences and the eye
movements that people are producing
between these different experiments and
what I'm showing here is just looking at
the cards that participants are
producing so there's a fast eye
movements jumping from one point to
another and then I look at the endpoints
of those circades and and I look at
where where those fall right and I took
into into account only the time between
well a and ball B coming into the scene
and and before basically when they
collide with one another that uh that
time window
and then and then we see that on this um
for the for the causal question a lot of
those cards basically end up along the
path right that Bobby would have taken
if ballet hadn't been there whereas in
the other condition we see very few of
these kinds of eye movements
um there was uh so so nice I guess even
more direct evidence that people are
engaging in this kind of process and
that they're doing it specifically when
asked to to answer a causal question
about the clip and sort of spontaneously
there is this other part um to it so um
that but I think I will um skip so I
have a little bit more time to um let me
see well actually I'll I'll share it
sorry sorry about that so there was
another you know after we published this
paper there was another reviewer number
two
as there often is right
um and and they they were basically
still saying like Okay well you know
this was for the eye tracking data and
they said like okay that's nice like
you're showing us these sort of eye
movements
um but they basically said that like
okay you know these eye movements
they're happening before the balls are
colliding with one another right and
you're calling it sort of counter
factual simulation kind of faction
should mean it should be you know back
in the past right going back in the past
evaluating that something would have
been different and then uh seeing what
difference that would have made
and so so they were and they were saying
oh what you should you should just call
it the hypothetical simulation model
instead and and not that so we were able
to kind of push back but um but but the
reviewer also was was right um to um to
some extent I think
so this is a paper that I've published
quite quite recently where I was trying
to um say that no you really need the
kind of factual so a lot of this has
been like yeah you really need the kind
of actuals and then you just keep
getting some pushback and you try to
convince people even more so
so this was this reviewer number two
here you haven't really shown us kind of
factual simulation those looks are
happening before the balls are colliding
so so his idea was well maybe what
people are doing is they're kind of
simulating some hypothetical future in
this case the hypothetical future is
like what would happen if ball a wasn't
there and then they're storing that in
their mind and comparing that to what
actually happened at the end so and
that's a slightly different computation
from the one that I think and they're
carrying out
and this relates to something again
here's um Judea Pearl this climbing on
this kind of virtual ladder here
um um because because he has argued that
there are these kind of three different
ways of thinking about the the extent to
which people have causal knowledge of
how the world works right
on the lowest rung of the letter and he
often accuses a lot of you know deep
learning and so on to be on that rung
although it's a little unclear
um he calls that run the level of
Association so that's what you learn in
the stats classes correlation right like
when two things are associated with one
another and you can infer one variable
from the presence of another so the
normal conditional probability right p p
y given I want to see a p y given X so
what does some symptom tell me about the
disease for example
on the next level is the level of
Interventional reasoning that's the kind
of when I do a randomized control trial
for example or if I'm again
hypothetically reasoning or what would
happen if I were to do this what would
happen if I were to do that right that's
and that's sort of when you then when
your Stats teacher tells you yeah
causation and correlation aren't the
same thing that's often the thing that
they didn't think about right that like
oh and the level of an experiment now
I'm performing an intervention randomly
assigning people to different groups and
I can draw different kinds of causal
inferences from that information then
when I just have um observations
but then process ultimately the kind of
the highest rung on the ladder is that
is reserved for counterfactual reasoning
and that allows you to give specific
answers essentially to why questions so
why did this happen in this particular
case like
um you know was it the aspirin that
stopped my headache or would it have
stopped anyhow even if it hadn't taken
the aspirin or you know was Kennedy shot
but Kennedy still have been alive if it
hadn't been shot by by Lee Harvey Oswald
and so essentially the other question
boils down to do we need that third
level like to explain people's causal
judgments or is the second one enough
right
um so just to kind of try and make it a
little more clear right so the
hypothetical luckily in English also we
have sort of a way of marking the
difference between them so here's an
English a hypothetical would B go into
the goal if a was removed so what you'd
be doing is taking the time into account
until they Collide simulating like a
possible future and then and Computing
the probability of that
versus the counter factual what I'm
doing slightly different in English
right would be have gone into the goal
if a had been removed I sometimes uh you
know regret having gotten into kind of
factual so much so they're obviously not
a native speaker and the kind of
factuals are sometimes a little
complicated right that you get the
tenses right and so on but I think I've
mostly gotten it down by now after like
20 years
so so what we have gotten to the goal if
ball a had been removed so you're doing
slightly slightly different here now
right you're taking into account
everything until the end and you're now
going back in time uh to do this
intervention and then think about how
the world could have unfolded
differently from how it actually did
so now it turns out in this very simple
setting here that makes no difference
the the hypothetical probability and the
count of action probability is the same
because there's nothing there's only
this one causal event happening so it
doesn't really come apart
so in a very simple setting where you
have one cause and one effect
essentially
um that you cannot tease the two apart
but you don't need to make it much more
complicated it's sufficient if you just
have one other alternative event that
you are initially uncertain about and
and that will make it such that now the
hypothetical probability and the kind of
factual probability will be different
from one another
so here was the genius invention just
putting like a little block again that
you've seen earlier but this time the
block is on Rails
into the scene and that will now make it
such that we can tease these two
different things apart so here's an
example I'm not going to ask for
audience position this time but um let's
say that this was happening in the clip
and now if you were asked to say oh did
it prevent it from going into the goal
my participants say in this case yes it
did right and the idea is why is it well
because the block you know moved out of
the way like in time right such that
Bobby would have gone through the goal
if poly hadn't been there right but you
may have also noticed that the the
movement of the block is happening you
know after the boss collided with one
another so not something that you could
have sort of anticipated at this earlier
moment in time or at least had some
uncertainty about
right so the the basic idea here right
is to say like oh a hypothetical
probability at the time would Ball B go
into the goal if ball a wasn't there
well that's unsure that depends on
whether or not the Block's gonna move
right so I should give it like a 0.5 or
something I told participants it's just
as likely to move as it's not
whereas for the counter factual
probability
um well I know that it moved in this
case right so I should be pretty certain
yeah that it would have gone in if
volley had been removed so now I have a
way basically of teasing the two apart
and can see which one better explains
the causal judgments right is it the
hypothetical judgments that ask
participants to do or is it the kind of
factual judgments that are asking
another group to do and then I ask one
group to um to give causal judgments
and then just try to relate them to one
another
and um and what I find like is when I
look at the hypothetical so maybe I
should say a little bit more about that
plot here at the bottom it basically
shows you the initial configuration of
the block right was it in the way or not
and then did it move yes or no right so
that's the so in this example here it's
one where it was initially in the way
but it moved right but in the
hypothetical condition you don't you
don't know that right because you only
see it until they pause and then if you
look at the hypothetical judgments they
think when it's initially in the weight
I think it's a little less likely that
it's going to go in when it's initially
out of the way I think it's a little bit
more likely right so there's a little
bit sticky in terms of um what actually
happened
for the count of action probabilities
pretty much only the final state is what
matters if it was out of the way at the
end you think yeah I would have gone in
if it was in the way at the end you
think it would have missed
and now if you ask people to make causal
judgments in this case we see that it
aligned very closely with the counter
factual ones and not with the
hypothetical ones and this was for the
kind of Miss cases but the same story
again holds essentially for the causal
cases too so they think that it caused
it when the block would have been in the
way at the end and they don't think that
it caused it when the block was would
have been out of the way at the end
so enough to make this review too happy
but maybe not Michael yeah
the there were two two things that
changed in that intervention there was
the question you asked the hypothetical
versus the counter factual it also
sounds like the
changes in how far they saw into the
video that's right that's right and
I'm I'm picturing the counter factual
situation where if you ask me the
hypothetical question but showed me the
full video so you I see a whole video
and then you say would be going to the
into the goal if a was removed like I
don't know how yeah yeah it's a tricky
one I mean I guess you know you'd have
to ask them like what did you think I
guess sort of at the time right like
before it happened did you think and and
people are often bad at that right we
know that from all the hindsight
research and so on that they have
difficulty putting themselves back into
the epistemic state I guess that they
had at an earlier point in time right
and so I'm not exactly I haven't tried
that one I haven't tried showing it
until the end but then asking them the
hypothetical question it's possible of
course that they will confuse it like as
a counterfactual question right and um
but but for me it was still sufficient I
guess at least to to address this
reviewer's concern because this idea was
really yeah that computation is
happening earlier but it's happening
before the causal event of interest and
then you're storing the output of that
computation in this case the
hypothetical probability and then just
comparing the that to what actually
happens at the end right so it still
felt that it's addressing that but um
yeah
some
okay so having these two things helps
helps teasing them apart
okay I'll sum up the first part and then
the second part will be will be short
but that's okay
so for this kind of factual simulation
model but I've showed you that there's
this sort of nice correspondence between
people's beliefs about the relevant
counterfactual and the causal judgments
that they make
that it looks like that these things are
necessary which you can show with the
teleport or with the with the brick in
and out of the way that people
spontaneously engage in this kind of
kind of actual simulation as evidence to
the eye movements and that it's kind of
factuals really and not hypotheticals
that seem to be important for expanding
causal judgments
we've played around with this model like
a little bit more once you have a hammer
right you find all the nails
um so this one is just like looking at
slightly more complex cases this one
here philosophers love because it's a
case of it again maybe a case of double
prevention where B prevents ball a from
preventing ball E from going through the
gate right because knocks it out it
happens in maybe in in football probably
happens often it one tackles like
another person that would have tackled
the person running with the ball right
and so you might say oh to what extent
did that cause it you can also look at
omissions when nothing is happening so
ball a is just chilling here in the
corner and you might still ask oh did it
go in because ball a didn't hit it right
and now you could imagine well if it had
hit it what would have happened in this
case
and we can also look at cases where
really nothing is happening at all so
it's just a tower of blocks right and
you might still wonder out to what
extent is this black one here
responsible for the other one staying on
the table and and even though yeah
there's nothing happening right you
might still say well how do you answer
this question Maybe by doing something
like playing Jenga in your mind right
imagining it being removed and then what
would have happened to the scene so that
even just physical support in some sense
is very closely related to to ideas of
causation right what it means to support
is essentially to prevent something from
falling in one way or another
okay so that was part one that was sort
of short version of um of Parts two
and so responsibility attribution was
something that I've been into yeah for
quite a while and was also my motivating
thing and then I drifted off into
causality world mostly just because
physics engines was around at the time
so it was like oh now I can use those
and with a round at the time I mean I
was I was a postdoc with Josh Tenenbaum
back then and physics engines were all
the rage at the time and I said okay now
I'll also use them and there aren't
really yet
um although I guess Mike was working on
it psychology engines right that is easy
where you could just have agents and
think about what they would have done
um so so this work that I had done on
responsibility tradition wasn't
particularly social also didn't really
involve simulation I think and there was
one experiment that got a little bit
closer that I'll briefly share with you
here
um on a paper called moral Dynamics and
it will look very Billy at wild world
like I haven't moved too far away from
the billiard balls but this kind of
somewhat agentive right so and so we
could show people like a video clip like
this and then ask them out of what
extent do you think that blue was
responsible that the green one got
harmed in this case here right
and our inspiration here came from a
paper called moral kinematics where they
basically argued again it's somewhat
more actualist of you and saying like
okay there's certain features that
people are picking up on in these scenes
like the duration of contact how far
things moved and things like that and
then they directly map from these
features of the scene to the moral
judgment in this case right
and we like the general setup but didn't
really like that model like um as much
so so we proposed another model that has
a slightly different title moral
Dynamics instead and when we thought
okay yeah these features are important
but the features are important in that
they give us evidence for the for the
latent variables and that those are
ultimately the ones that I care about
and in this case what are the latent
ones that we thought one not very
surprisingly here on the right hand side
causality but did you think that it
actually caused it you know to um to to
for this negative outcome to happen and
then the left side the intuitive
psychology part very kind of minimal in
this case here but it's basically saying
like well maybe these features give you
some evidence about like how much the
agent actually wanted to bring about
this negative outcome so if you think
for example if somebody really wants
something to happen then they're willing
to incur a larger cost to make it happen
right like putting a lot of effort for
example so if somebody puts in a lot of
effort into something you know that they
must have really valued it and if
somebody really valued some negative
outcome well that's a bad thing right
that was roughly the idea here
and we could then show that if we have a
model that just basically infers the
amount of effort that some agent um
exerted and try to map that onto the
responsibility that worked kind of you
know okay-ish
if we only took into account the causal
role that some agent played and try to
use that to explain the extent to which
they are held responsible that worked
okayish but if we now took a model that
takes both of these components into
account that worked pretty well which
was roughly in line with this kind of
unsurprisingly now
um this framework that I laid out at the
beginning right that when we assign
responsibility to others we don't just
care about the causal role that they
played but also what the action tells me
about the kind of person that they are
and in this case the action tells me
something about the desire that they had
to bring about this negative outcome
okay but still they won't we didn't
really have a Model A real model of
agents in this case we still sort of
basically just use the physics engine
um also we weren't able to talk about
intentions and it's clearly important
often when people talk about
responsibility and also still our kind
of factual simulation here was basically
purely physical just think how this how
this thing would have moved without the
other one
so so I don't have the skills you know
to make it happen with um you know with
with with sort of more agentive agents
but luckily now that I'm here you know I
get to work out with all these smart
people and here's my PhD student Sarah
Wu and our research assistant and
they've looked into cases now that are a
little bit more agentive they're still
kind of in in Grid world but um
but at least now planning and intentions
and things like that are involved and
here's the basic setup so this is
inspired by some previous work that has
looked into helping and hindering as
like a case a case study right and and
what they did is essentially they said
like well what it means for somebody to
intend to help someone is that they
their utility function includes the
other person's utility with a positive
sign right intending to help just means
like yeah wanting to bring positive
utility at least in this framework to
the other person and intending to hinder
puts a negative sign like now I wanted
that the other person is a low utility
right
um so turns out though that like
intending to help or hinder versus
actually helping or hindering is not
necessarily the same thing right so
here's here's an example I don't have a
child yet but at some point maybe we'll
have a child and then if I go grocery
shopping with the child there probably
will be a period of time where they're
not actually helping right they're sort
of like trying to help right but like
kind of making it worse right at least
in terms of efficiency and so on it's
going to take longer of course it's
useful because eventually they will be
helpful I have to go through that
process just like a PhD student
oh
laughs
so so yeah so you go through that
process you know and then you might
intend to be helpful but it might take a
little bit of time to actually be
helpful
and so and the claim is right to to
evaluate that you need kind of factuals
again to tell oh is the person actually
helpful well how would it have happened
you know without them essentially or
there's different kind of factions to
consider but that's one of them
so here's our grid world that we played
with with the helping and handing
hindering setup so we have this red guy
here who wants to get to the star as a
pure physical goal in this case just got
to that location then we have this blue
one who has a pure social goal they
either want to help or hinder the red
one from getting there and then there
are these walls here that you you know
can't do anything about but there's also
these blocks and only the only the blue
one can interact with these blocks it
can move push pull them you know out of
the way so here's our Hollywood clip of
what's happening in this situation
okay so in this case you know happy
happy end like like a Hollywood movie
um you know Red made it and then we can
show people these clips and we can ask
them oh how responsible was the blue
player for the red player's success for
example in this trial we can also ask
them a kind of factual question right
with the red player still have succeeded
even if the blue player hadn't been
there okay
and we can ask them to make an inference
about the intention of the blue one in
this case but was the blue player
intending to do were they trying to help
or were they trying to hinder or
definitely help definitely Hinder
so the idea is now it's basically the
same as earlier by the saying okay again
we need some kind of generative model of
the domain in this domain now it's a
model of Agents basically planning and
recursively reasoning about one another
right
um and that's now our probabilistic
program and we can again compute counter
factuals over that maybe and again in
this case thinking well what would have
happened if the blue one hadn't been
there and then thinking how the red one
would have planned their path
differently but without the presence
like of of blue that's the rough idea so
again we take some actual situation and
we can then simulate what would have
happened in the relevant counterfactual
situation in this case where blue hadn't
been there we can talk later if you like
about other kind of factuals you might
consider but we just went with this one
here but what if they hadn't been there
in this case yeah they wouldn't have
made it because the block was in the way
right
um we also have a model of intention
inference but I'll sort of skip that
it's basically just saying okay if you
have a generative model about what in
helping or hindering agent would do you
can then condition on the observations
that you see them acting and see what's
more what's more likely that they were
helping or hindering given the actions
that They carried out
so I'll just give you a few more
examples of the sort of video clips that
we show to participants
that's a diagram of the one that you've
just seen here's another one
where kind of
you know blue sort of extra mean you
might say there was already a block in
the way but they put another Block in
the way
what the heck yeah really trying to be
helpful through adversarial actions
so here's another one here where um
blue is sort of audibly helpful but like
you know
was not really necessary but maybe looks
nice
um here's a case in which sort of things
go wrong
where blue was maybe trying to be
helpful but actually sort of made it
worse you know the reactions that they
took
um and then here's another one we had we
had a large number so I'm just showing
like a subset of them
um so this is one where blue could have
easily hindered if they had wanted to
right but didn't because they could have
just pushed it into the way
um
and so then we now have to again yeah
try to capture whether we can with our
model capture the counter factual um
judgments that people are making and we
sort of can there's not as much kind of
variance here at least in the
predictions of the model so this model
is sort of okay-ish it captures the
trends overall but there's more variance
in people's judgments that it's not
quite captured by the model yet so we're
still this is sort of more more ongoing
work
um in terms of intention inference it's
it's fine so it can also kind of infer
whether the person was helping or
hindering but also here but you see a
stuffer bunched up that the model all
gives 100 to where there's still some
differentiation
um that people make but sort of mostly
captures what's going on
and if we now look at the responsibility
judgments and we try to do the same
thing initially that we did with the
billiard balls earlier if we just take
the counter factuals like on the x-axis
and try to predict the responsibility
here on the on the y-axis it's okay-ish
but not you always want right when you
do computational modeling you always
want them nicely line up on the diagonal
and that's not really what was happening
in this case right whereas for the
billiard balls we had this very simple
the counter factuals nicely predict um
the causal ratings
but if again if you have a model that
incorporates also the intention
inferences like into the predictions now
they do sort of more nicely line up on
the diagonal again suggesting that when
it comes to assigning responsibility for
agents it's not just the causal role
that matters it also matters what the
actions that they took tell me about the
kind of person that they are in this
case it tells me something about their
intentions like they try to be helpful
or did they try to be hindering so both
of these components
and just to give you a sense of an
example where we need this kind of
intention part like that's back to that
mean one where the blue one pushes
another one into the way right and so
just to help you kind of interpret the
bars here the counter factual that's the
condition where we ask them what red
would red have succeeded if blue hadn't
been there that's basically our causal
model and they don't think so right the
the
pink purplish one is like very low right
um but also when we ask them what the
intention of the blue one is they think
yeah it was really hindering so here
zero means hindering and 100 means
helping so they think yeah they were
hindering
so even though they say that yeah the
the blue one didn't really play a causal
role they still give them quite a bit of
responsibility like in the blue one on
the right hand side so that's one case
at least where currently we need this um
this other part so they think yeah Blues
actually make no difference but they
were definitely trying to hinder and so
yeah I still give them some
responsibility for this outcome
okay so sort of almost last slide
um because we have these agents like um
recursively thinking about one another
an interesting setting that also can
happen here is that you can actually
hinder or help one another again maybe
also like in the in the advisor advisory
setting not by actually making any
change to the physical world but
changing somebody else's belief so I
just want to give show you that example
and maybe we'll get that intuition from
the setting here
so very very mean very very sad
it looked really like blue was not right
and then they didn't right that's the
team project exactly yeah
and here's just one participant what
they're saying oh blue tricked read into
thinking she was going to move the box
to help but then once red was stuck on
the side of the wall blue left the box
where it was very sad you know and and a
lot of people say something along those
lines we also had one condition where we
just have them give explanations of what
happened right and here the interesting
part right is that the hindering is not
happening because blue changed anything
about the world they didn't move a block
in the way or something but they hinder
it because they made red belief that
they were going to be helpful and then
they weren't right yeah blue hadn't been
there red would have just walked along
on the outside and they might have made
it you know anyhow even without Bloom
and this happens because they're
recursively thinking about one another
right and read things like oh blue is
taking action so they're going to help
me so I can go I can take the shortcut
and then turns out I couldn't in this
case
okay wrapping up
um so this was the second part where we
I guess applied this model now to at
least a simple setting where agents are
interacting with one another
um helping and hindering one another
um that in order to judge whether
somebody helped or hinder I again think
that you need this process of kind of
factual simulation and um and that
responsibility judgments are sensitive
both to the cause of all that somebody
played and what their actions tell us
about the kind of mental state that they
had
just to conclude so together hopefully
this sort of set of studies get some
evidence that people seem to be
constructing these rich mental mental
models of the world that we can get
evidence for in different kinds of ways
like through eye tracking and other
tools
um by imagining interventions like on
these mental models
um those allow us to compute the counter
factuals which I think are important for
assigning responsibility giving
explanations and so on
and that this kind of factual simulation
model that I've been kind of developing
can then be relatively flexibly applied
to physical and social events where you
think that the main thing that's
happening is that your model of the
world changes and maybe the exact kind
of factual operation that you're
carrying out changes but otherwise the
framework sort of holds so with that I
want to thank the main people who helped
me do this kind of work and then maybe
you for your attention and there's a
little bit of time for questions
you got a question please grab the mic
from
so one thing I'm curious is I assume
Notions of causality are probably
somewhat Universal but especially issues
of moral judgment intention or likely
dependent to some extent on
environmental factors cultural factors
those kinds of things and so I'm curious
if you've either observed those in your
experiments or if you have some way of
controlling for those factors when you
recruit participants yeah so that's
that's an interesting question and um
and I think even even Notions of
causality actually there are there are
cultural um effects like where you what
you know yeah who you see the so so when
when making causal judgments right
there's often there's basically like um
in many cases um what's called the
problem of causal selection how do I
even decide what thing to pick out on as
the cause in the first place right in my
setting very often I've kind of made it
pretty easy and I've sort of constrained
it because I already put told you like
these are the possible causes right
um but in the real world it's not like
that right and it's sometimes you know
we may see something we may see a person
as a cause or we may see a system as a
cause but or we may also the kind of
counter factuals that may come to mind
to us may also depend on what our
background is right and it often tells
us something about oh when somebody then
gives a certain counter factual it tells
us quite a bit about them right so this
comes up in the context for example also
of victim blaming like if that's the
kind of action that came to mind to you
right oh that tells me something like um
about you so I would say that even even
in that context text right there are a
strong kind of you know interpersonal
and cultural effects that affect how we
attribute causality right now when it
comes to intention inferences I'm not
sure that that process in and of itself
that at least to me feels relatively um
you know
um whatever Universal right that we kind
of that we have to engage in that all
the time by trying to predict what other
people are intending the way that we
um uh interact with them but then again
how maybe then
um judgments in this case of
responsibility or morality like draw on
these different components for example
that I've laid out here I yeah no claim
that that is in any sense sort of you
know like Universal but it might very
well be that in certain cultures like
this kind of what I take here to be more
the person component right may have a
stronger influence like on
responsibility judgments and in others
it might mostly be about
um causality I certainly in my
experiments uh um for individual
participants see a lot of variants along
the lines but there's some people that
don't care about even the intention part
at all they just say like oh Ben it's
about responsible I just look at what
would have happened if they if they
hadn't been there right and then other
participants judgments are
suggesting that they care about the
intention part much more right but I
have not yet um engaged in the kind of
work that then tries to explain why is
it why is it that this person cares so
much about causality and why is it that
this person you know cares so much about
the intention part for example thank you
I'm gonna hug the mic actually uh I I'm
interested uh like do you think this
model applies to other settings because
all of the examples were sort of like
physical or agents taking physical
action so if you had just like a verbal
description of some social scenario
where there's like speech acts that are
causing things do you think it would
work the same and yeah yeah that's a
great question
um
so would it work the same so my sense is
like yeah in a similar way
um
says a number of things here I think so
so we have applied the model a little
bit like the the this kind of contextual
simulation model in the physical world
also two speech acts and and there it's
in the context of like uh we were
basically jealous of you know Phil
wolves for those who remember for Wolf
yet these different words right and we
were like oh our model can only do like
cause and prevent that's kind of sad but
there's other causal expressions of
course right it enabling affecting
leading allowing and so on and um it's
going to be a little bit of a domain but
I'll get there so we were trying to to
see to what extent this framework that
we have could also allow us to explain
differences between these different um
Expressions right and
um and this also comes up um you know in
philosophy like even questions but the
question versus killing versus causing
to die even people like in cases of
abortion you know the way that you talk
about it right again reveals something
you know how you think about it and in
general right like this distinction also
when you have that as an alternative
that you could have said killing but you
chose causing to die it suggests Maybe
more roundabout way in which something
happened right like the person killed
calls them to die you think yeah it
would be weird to say it that someone
caused them to die when they like you
know directly walked up to them and you
know shot them this also came up
recently are still coming up these days
actually with um the case of Alec
Baldwin rust like in the movie right the
way that people talk about it was that
well hold the gun that discharged or
something rather than you know shot the
person right so it matters a lot
basically like um in this case the
choice of word right and the and the in
some sense the counter factual
Alternatives that you could have had but
for then the image that it's creating in
The Listener in this case right so the
fact that oh you chose this expression
suggests to me that the scenario must
have been such like rather than such so
that's at least the minimal way I think
in which it applies also to to thinking
about speech acts right and thinking
like yeah and of course you could think
like oh you know again take the advisor
example with the students still have
done that if I had not said that right
um so we're obviously causing each other
a lot in the way that we talk to each
other and sometimes you know yeah also
of course after talking about I might
think like oh I wish I had I had
answered this question from differently
than what I actually did and I regret it
right and things like that
yeah um so on a similar note I'm
wondering if you have thoughts on how
possible it would be to use this model
on society large-scale societal events
there are divisive such as what caused a
person to be elected because outbreaks
or what causes
um uh climate change like how possible
would it be to apply this to those
events and also what challenges you
foresee yeah yeah that's a great
question and and so
um
so I had the example for example at the
beginning with like oh did the fall of
Lehman Brothers caused the financial
crisis right that's sort of like and I
don't know right and and partly it might
so and there's a few options right one
is like okay just like totally punting
right and saying like Okay well if the
system gets sufficiently complex such
that I cannot carry out the relevant
counterfactual computation anymore well
I just don't know right I cannot give
that causal answer right that's that's
one version right then there's another
version where you say like okay well to
the extent that I can maybe you know
abstract away from a lot of the lower
level details let's say of some uh so if
I'm if I'm if I have the capacity to
build maybe a more abstract model which
which I can now simulate right then I
might be giving you an answer sort of on
that level right and so but then it's
also half punting right because now you
have to kind of come up with a good um
model of how people generate the right
kind of causal abstractions for some
situation that then allow them to
compute the kind of factual because now
it's not messy anymore right and another
thing that I should mention and that
quite a lot of the work
um on responsibility that I've that I've
looked to particularly in groups the
sort of situations that you um pointed
out like elections and you know global
warming they're they're characterized by
by large degrees of over determination
right like an election you hardly ever
cast a pivotal vote right
um um and so those also traditionally
were problems for kind of factual
accounts like because everybody can say
like I made no difference like if I fly
every day you know that's not really
going to make a difference and so
um and there you can in similar
reflection why should I go vote right
because if my vote's not going to make
any difference right and there at least
models have been built that then say
like okay well
um it's not you're not off the hook
right it's basically saying um even if
you would not have made a difference in
this particular situation maybe the
degree of responsibility that you have
for some election for example may be
related to how close you were to making
a difference to the outcome but if it's
like if the outcome is six five you feel
irresponsible if it's like um seven four
a little less if it's like eight three a
little less right but not but it
shouldn't go to zero right and then and
then as it maybe now relates to kind of
you know global warming and so on part
of the challenge then from the more like
you know what do we do about it um uh
side might be like okay how do we make
it such that people don't perceive a
sort of you know going to zero sense of
responsibility right such that you feel
like actually the actions that you do um
make a difference to the outcome and so
yeah so that's so I think
a mix of uh thoughts I guess in response
to your question
if you're logging attendance make sure
to grab one of these code words up at
the front and give Toby a compliment on
the stock on your way up if I make you
come up next to it
um let's thank our speaker